mic Tang was charged with child
endangerment for leaving his 8 year old
son in this parking lot a mile from home
it was supposed to be a life lesson the
night where I dropped him off I just
wanted to reinforce that money is hard
to earn and doesn't do a good job at
school he could end up you know doing
something like this or sleeping out here
where the homeless people sleep he
dropped him not far from the recycling
area and walked away
sometimes as a guy there and you see
people on bikes they looked kind of
ragged could be homeless Mike says his
son Isaac had been slacking in school
the last straw was when Mike caught
Isaac cutting corners on his homework by
reading his little sister's book instead
of his own it's an 8 year old kid who
didn't read his book right why would you
do that well first of all I've tried
other things right and they didn't work
so that's my take on it and I'm trying
different things if this doesn't work I
might try something else next time about
10 to 15 minutes after dropping Isaac
Mike sent Isaac's grandfather to go pick
him up
it was 8 o'clock and getting dark turns
out Isaac had already been picked up he
was in police custody a stranger had
spotted Isaac and called the cops
he says why was I walking home and did I
know where my home was and did you you
know how to walk home from the park yeah
I know why welcome to my school to my
house the cops arrested Mike and he
spent the night in County Jail a jury
later convicted him and the judge
sentenced him to attend parenting
classes and to a 56 day work release
program picking up the trash Mike is
refusing to serve the sentence and
there's an outstanding warrant for his
failure to comply he scrawled a response
on top of the warrant and mailed it back
[ __ ] you all walking on a public street
a sidewalk at 7:45 p.m. is not child
endangerment is Mike right or did he
jeopardize Isaac safety and was it
appropriate for the police to intervene
my saying is one of the many American
parents who decided to give their kids
some independence in this case as a
disciplinary measure who have their
parenting second-guessed by the
authorities and find themselves arrested
journalist Lenore Kennedy is the founder
of the free range kids movement walking
home a mile on a route that the kid
already knew does not rise to the level
of danger it rises to the level of
unusual it rises to the level of perhaps
controversial but it was not literally
dangerous that's not a crime the state
of California says child endangerment
occurs when someone willfully causes or
permits a child to be placed in a
situation where his or her person or
health is endangered did Mike endanger
Isaac their hometown of Corona has a
remarkably low crime rate and Isaac knew
how to get home and properly use
crosswalks police and County officials
refused to comment for this story but
court transcripts from Mike's trial give
us a sense of the arresting officers
thinking witness in my opinion if I was
in your shoes
I wouldn't have left my child there I
have a 20 year old daughter that I would
not let her walk the 20 year old walking
home in a safe town is not safe enough
what is when we hate the parent for what
they're doing we think they're wrong we
automatically over inflate the danger
that we see the kid in there was a study
done at the University of California at
Irvine asking people how much danger a
kid was in when the parents let the
child wait alone in the car it turns out
that the safety of the children wasn't
what mattered most to the people
surveyed in the study they were actually
passing moral judgment on the parent so
if a mom lets the kid wait in the car
because accidentally she was hit by a
truck and she was out cold that's okay
the kid isn't in so much danger but if
she was going to meet her lover and let
the kid in the car oh my god we think
the kid is in way more danger we are
making moral judgments every time we see
a kid unsupervised and the more we hate
the parent for leaving the child
unsupervised the more in danger we think
the kid is maybe this is not the way you
would discipline your child it's not the
way I disciplined my kids but he's
trying his best and to treat parenting
like a spectator sport and if you
wouldn't have done it that way and I
think that was wrong nobody thinks that
any other parent is raising their kids
right but if you're a cop and you have
the power to arrest and then you're a
jury and you have the power to hang you
are giving too much power over an
individual parenting decisions to the
state if I had to do it all over again
you know I do the same thing
because of his refusal to serve his
sentence
Mike faces possible jail time if I don't
have the freedom to discipline my kid if
they don't even have the freedom to walk
outside I'm already in prison right now
so what does it matter if I go to prison
or not
[Music]
[Music]